In this next section, we're going
to look at some key technologies for ICD effects,
including our virtual production technology family tree.
So this is something that we are
in the process of developing.
It's just basically a visual guide
to show you where a lot of the different technologies that
are implemented in ICD effects, where they reside,
and how and what are involved with them.
I mean, if you look just on a basic level,
we talk about Perforce, Unreal Engine,
and the various stage engineering requirements.
We're going to get into the stage engineering
requirements in a little bit.
But if we look specifically under Unreal Engine,
we have some things to call out here.
Virtual scouting, real-time environments, digital humans,
camera, the LED wall itself, of course,
various compositing technology, and what's
needed for practical lights.
And as you can see, there's a number of additional tools
and capabilities within Unreal Engine
that are derived by these specific needs.
For virtual scouting, of course, we
have the implementation of VR and LIDAR scans.
Real-time environments, well, there's
Crixal, which is a product that you should become
available with the various mega scans that
can help to populate your virtual environments.
The digital human aspect of all of this,
there is Metahumans, which is something
that has been released about a year ago, maybe
a little bit more.
This implements various technologies
like Control Rig and Live Link, along
with various facial capture systems
that Epic has utilized to do live facial capture using
an iOS device, like an iPhone.
And then there's also the various elements
of being able to integrate animation
in from various DCC applications, traditional animation
and traditional characters and how they're rigged.
And then to the camera itself, how do we track a camera?
And again, it's utilizing a lot of the Live Link protocols
that we've developed in order to communicate
back and forth between objects and Unreal Engine.
There is the number of different IO cards
that we utilize for bringing in visual imagery
from the camera, whether they're using Blackmagic cards
or Kona cards, these are ways in order
to get visual information into the engine
that you can use for all kinds of different purposes.
There's the LED wall, of course,
and all the associated technologies there,
end display, switchboard, web remote,
all of these are different technologies
and capabilities that you'll be learning
throughout this particular program.
And then also compositing with composer
and practical lighting capabilities
and being able to control lights through DMX.
Now, these key virtual production technologies,
there's some in specific that I wanna call out.
First are a series of production design tools.
So production design is unquestionably
one of the most important aspects
of the whole LED volume in-camera visual effects process.
You need to be able to adequately create
and prepare the items that you plan to shoot,
whether it's practically or virtually.
So in a virtual setting, we wanna talk about
being able to do virtual set scouting.
We wanna be able to combine various GIS data,
LIDAR data, drone scanning, and so forth
in order to create the worlds that you plan to shoot.
And this can be very important
when you're trying to decide
how much needs to be practically shot
versus how much can be done inside of an LED wall.
And when you have these environments scanned and built,
they can be really crucial, critical even,
for your planning process in pre-production.
How great would it be to be able
to basically have a scan of the environment
of where you're planning to eventually shoot
live action elements in?
From there, you can set scout
and look at all of the different options available to you.
There's also some key virtual production technologies
for various visualization tools.
Now, I talked about previs.
Previs was a very early forerunner
to a lot of the processes and workflows
that we're utilizing and observing
in the ICV effects process.
But now with real-time previs,
you have the option of basically being more iterative
and having the ability to interact with the data
and have potentially your director,
your visual effects supervisor, your cinematographer,
all being able to come in and look at Unreal
in order to provide their feedback in real time.
You can do character blocking,
you can do virtual camera blocking,
and all of this can be either done on the day
or potentially, again,
using the multi-user capabilities inside of Unreal,
you could potentially have the ability for your director,
your cinematographer, your motion capture actors,
all in different locations,
working together in session within Unreal Engine.
This will, again, ultimately feed the whole ability
to create some really nice preliminary sequence designs
and constructions,
which can feed the whole creative process.